notre regard des candidates qui qui ne
me fera pas de cadeau
c'est christian maxime un personnage
haut en couleur ça va christian on
t'appelle christian on t'appelle maxime
qui qui savent à qui qui qui est venu
avec qui je suis pas bon et j'ai vu avec
lui il est pas là pas voulu montrer sa
grande tête à la télé qu'est-ce qui fait
comme métier papa
mais je ne crache pas dessus je
m'efforce alors je postillonne déboires
qu'est ce que tu vas chanter une chanson
nana mouskouri elle chante cette chanson
ah bon parce que pris tu aimes mes
chansons de noël mouskouri tu aimes par
les changements de nanas et comment tu
la trouves pas ça hudon paquette
moi je lui cracher dessus et toi t'es
moche